c'est bon si vous voulez y aller sur la
gauche
oh
voire trop tard
nous on vient du pas de calais et qu'est
ce que vous faites on va à paris pour le
convoi de la liberté pourquoi pas pour
notre liberté justement qu'est ce qui
vous a motivé à venir comme ça là
risquent de pas on et gilet jaune depuis
trois ans on n'arrête pas de crier notre
colère est la personne qui nous écoutent
et puis là avec toutes ces mesures
sanitaires si plus possible que via un
moment donné et puis toutes les
augmentations le gasoil partout leur
nourriture et on n'arrive plus à vivre
vraiment
n'a pas d'âge
on est dans les bouchons l'aca ce bail
pour un contrôle de gendarmerie
et pourquoi on sait pas
veux tu qu'on voit ça a expliqué fortis
il pouvoir c'est simplement
oui